In 1968, the Germans at QuickBorner Design didn't just build an office they engineered a psychological experiment.
They called it the Berlandschaft, the office landscape, a place where walls dissolved into thin air, where hierarchy was supposed to vanish like a mirage.
The idea was beautiful, fluid communication, collaboration without barriers, the death of the cubicle tomb.
But what emerged instead was something far more insidious.
The walls didn't disappear. They just moved inside your head.
This is how corporate gaslighting begins.
You don't just hate your job. You hate yourself for hating it.
The system doesn't fail you. You fail to adapt.
The chaos isn't institutional. It's your inability to stay agile.
And the language? Oh, the language. Oh, the language is the real weapon.
A failed project isn't a management disaster. It's a learning opportunity.
Being asked to do three jobs at once isn't exploitation. It's expanding your scope.
The words are designed to dissolve reality itself, so that when you look for the source of your misery, all you find is your own reflection in the glass.
The architecture of self-doubt is built on four pillars.
First, there's the culture trap.
They'll tell you this isn't a workplace. It's a family.
And families don't talk about money.
So when your paycheck feels like a joke, you laugh along.
You internalize the script.
I'm part of something greater.
A raise would be selfish.
The moment you question it, you've already lost.
Then comes the performance review ritual.
Even if you've crushed every metric, even if your numbers are flawless, you'll find something to punish yourself with.
I wasn't proactive enough in the synergy session.
I need to improve my emotional intelligence.
The system rewards self-flagellation.
The more you beat yourself, the more they pretend you're growing.
And grows in their world is just another word for compliance.
Next is the feedback loop of doom.
Seek advice from anyone who'll give it competent or not.
And when you get two contradictory answers, follow both.
Now you're pleasing no one, not even yourself.
Your brain is a battlefield.
And the only casualty is your ability to trust your own judgment.
And finally, there's SlackSync surveillance.
The red dot on your screen isn't a notification, it's a leash.
Five minutes of uninterrupted thought?
That's a crime.
Availability becomes competence.
And soon, you're measuring your worth in seconds, not hours.
The less time you have to yourself, the more they convince you that you're the problem.
The endgame?
You become a human pivot.
No fixed center.
No real north.
Just a body that can be spun in any direction.
A mind that accepts whatever goal they hand you.
A soul that blames itself for the system's failures.
Forty hours a week, for a purpose you don't understand.
Trusting a manager who doesn't deserve it.
And the worst part?
You'll do it willingly.
Because the real genius of corporate gaslighting isn't the open plan office.
It's the bathroom.
That's the only place the gaslighting stops.
The only place you can step away from the noise.
The only place you can try to rebuild a wall between you and them.
But even there, the system has its claws.
The prisoner who loves his cell doesn't need a guard.
And the employee who loves the culture, they don't need a raise.
They already have everything they'll ever need.